good day everyone and welcome i'm jack
van horn from the university of virginia
please allow me to welcome you to this
edition of our 2020 2021 foundations of
biomedical data science seminar series
this lecture supported by uva's
integrated translational health
institute of virginia
the uva brain institute the college of
arts and sciences
the school of data science and by grant
from the national institutes of general
medical sciences
it is my honor and privilege today to
welcome our speaker
dr evo dinov from the university of
michigan
he earned his bachelor of science degree
from sophia university in sofia bulgaria
in 1991 followed by two master's degrees
one at the michigan technological
university
and another from florida state
university followed by his phd
also from florida state university in
tallahassee
dr denov is professor of health and
behavior
health behavior and biological sciences
and computational medicine
and bioinformatics at the university of
michigan prior to his current position
at michigan dr denov was on the faculty
in statistics at the university of
california los angeles for many years
at michigan dr dinov serves as the
director of the statistics online
computational resource
and is an expert in mathematical
modeling statistical analysis
high throughput computing scientific
visualization of
big biomedical data sets his applied
research is focused on neuroscience
nursing informatics multimodal
biomedical image analysis
and distributed genomic computing
examples of specific brain research
projects in which dr denov is involved
include longitudinal morphometric
studies of development
of the developing brain and autism as
well as in psychiatry and schizophrenia
brain maturation um also diseases such
as depression
and phenomenon such as pain perception
and
in aging and alzheimer's disease as well
as in parkinson's
disease he also studies the intricate
relations between genetic traits
clinical phenotypes and subject
demographics in a variety of brain as
well as heart related
clinical disorders dr denov is currently
working to develop
and validate and disseminate novel
technology enhancing pedagogical
approaches for science education and
active learning
dr dino's lecture today is entitled big
data neuroscience
data sharing and predictive health
analytics and as always if you are
streaming this lecture live and for
recording by uh
so we are streaming this lecture live
and for recording via youtube
if you are watching via youtube thank
you so much for joining us
also our specially selected 2020 2021
biomedical data science innovation lab
participants are strongly encouraged
to submit any questions for dr dino via
the chat feature
in their zoom sessions i will personally
synthesize these questions and ask them
on your behalf during the last 10
minutes or so
of the lecture and with that thank you
so much evo we sure appreciate you
sharing your work with us today
thanks again we look forward to it
thank you very much dr van horn i
appreciate the invitation
it's a great pleasure to be here thank
you for joining as well so
um in my uh talk today i'll speak about
some of the
big neuroscience and data sharing
challenges and show you some examples of
techniques that we've developed
specifically for predictive health
analytics now by the way for those who
are interested
uh the slides i'm a firm believer of
open science
if it's not online it doesn't exist for
me so the slides are available online if
you google soccer news go to
today's date you'll find the slides so
that you can follow up
more closely if you like so in this talk
um i've broken it into three pieces that
will hopefully make
sense to to folks and they kind of build
on top of each other we're going to
start first by discussing some of the
open
open science pillars that are important
especially when you talk about big
neuroscience data
then in the second theme i'll present
some health analytics challenges and
more specifically
describe a technique that we recently
developed called data sifter
that does a novel statistical
obfuscation
that breaks a very important barrier in
science how do we share data
effectively and securely without
compromising
personal information and in the last
part of the talk i'll show you some
case studies specifically lou gehrig's
disease
amyotrophic later sclerosis then the
second example would be with the
uh population census like neuroscience
based on the uk biobank data
and then finally i'll tell you about
some really exciting technique that we
are
publishing this year something called
space
time analytics where time refers to
complex time
so with that let's just start in the
very beginning you know
what is open science and what are the
the key constituents
so on one level you know the obvious the
usual suspects right
the data metadata describing the data
experimental designs
you know you need hardware you need
software you need tools
and then you need on the next level you
need cloud services
transdisciplinary collaborations and
then what streams out of these
multiple levels of sources and
infrastructure is results
findings discoveries that are typically
shared or published or communicated
somehow
with with the rest of the community so
these are the the core principles and
you know um they're very important to
realize and i know
most of us probably already have that
understanding
in terms of what are the characteristics
and the challenges
that are involved in big biomedical and
more specifically neuroscience data
so in this table here on in the left
column i list
the the seven big dimensions or
characteristics or properties of big
data that we see
and the next column explains why are
these important and how do they
present technical and non-technical
challenges so for example
you know these big neuroscience data
sets they're sizable they're
volumes and you know the notion of uh
harvesting and managing vast amounts of
information is a huge challenge you know
we're talking about zetabytes of data
and i'll show you some graphs very soon
second of all the data is is very
complex it's not just spreadsheets it's
not just structured data
it requires wrangling it requires
manipulation of heterogeneous
data elements and so forth so very
significant challenges
this data is very often times
incongruent which presents
problems when you have to make it
computable data objects you need to do
some aggregation you need to do some
harmonization of data to make it
computable
many times the data arrives from
multiple sources as i'll show you
that are not intended designed
or necessarily interoperable so there is
a whole bunch of
challenges with the transferring the
joint multivariate representation
and that's where the beef of the work is
and modeling of some of these data
the data is often times multi-scale so
we can look at the same brain
from the macroscopic level of the mri
or the pet imaging at one millimeter
resolution down to the
mesoscale the microscale and the
nanoscale you can go on the angstrom
resolution if you have the right
device so the same sample the same
substrate
can be looked at multiple scale how do
you actually do the analytics
on something that's on multiscale it's
an open problem
this data very often times has a
longitudinal demand
requires techniques that are very
sensitive to these
intrinsic temporal correlations that are
embedded in the data and finally but
certainly not less
important is the fact that this data is
never complete so you need
very powerful methods to
impute and manage some of these data and
this is just one example here on the
right hand side with parkinson's disease
where we have
thousands of individuals and ten
thousands of biomarkers
that we've published on and and you know
the managing
requires a lot of manipulation now on
this slide
uh it is important for us to have a 30
000 feet
interpretation of what is really big
data you know how does it fall between
a census of the native process the
native processes in the left column here
and on the right hand side what is the
classical
observational data inference right small
samples
so in this example here suppose you have
the gold blue
is your data this image is your data
this is the natural process
it's most of the time natural processes
are not observable
samples from these natural processes are
observable and that what we see
well the big data is the stuff that's
gone in between right
it's got a little bit more data it could
be also misleading it's got a lot of
problems
you know the samples are limited in this
case there are a bunch of assumptions
randomness independence identical
distributions and whatnot
here in this space most of these
assumptions are broken there is all
kinds of other problems
but we're going to be operating for the
purpose of this talk we're going to be
operating in this middle layer here
between the natural processes and
classical
traditional sample based inference
now in this slide what i'm trying to
make is a very simple argument
data science is about information
compression
so you know the notion that um
in 200 years you know from 1798 when
henry cavendish
did this incredible uh experiment
by measuring the mean the the mean
density of the earth
by 23 observations you know it was
incredible
the guy was a very clever
scientist polymath for that matter uh
that acquired 20 23 observations to
measure the mean density of the earth
because he was interested in
what is the mass of the earth because
having the mass of the earth
is going to tell you what the attraction
forces with celestial bodies are right
the moon
the sun you know having an accurate
estimate of the mass of the earth is
critical
now obviously the volume you can
extrapolate but the density the mean
density when you multiply the volume by
the density that kind of gives you the
mass
and his estimate was that it's
about 5.4 times the density of a water
molecule
give or take a little bit okay turns out
his estimate is with the current precise
estimate of the mean density
uh the mean density of the earth is
precisely within the confidence limit
that cavendish estimated with 23
observations
now in the current point in time most of
us realize that 23 is not going to get
you anywhere you need 2 to the 23
observations
which by the way is 10 million to to get
anything interesting out of data and
that's where we are we're
in this space where the scalability and
the data compression needs to come in
and play an important role in the
scientific discovery
now in this little diagram before we get
into the more technical aspects i want
to outline
a typical pipeline workflow of how
big neuroscience data projects evolve
in the left column you start off
typically withdrawal
bits and bytes and surveys and blood
tests and all kinds of other
measurements
that by themselves are very um
kind of structured right but we're not
interested in these bits and bytes we're
interested in
information that they carry and in this
little
schematic i'm kind of illustrating how
the bits and bytes that represent
photon precessions are converted
into flat images okay two-dimensional
images
and these are observable objects we can
actually reconstruct this
what's not observable is the cortical
surface which we now
go on a tertiary level you see
we reconstructed by infusing models with
real observations
to actually deduce the folding of the
brain
and once you have this kind of
information
that leads you to knowledge and the
knowledge allows you to
you know parcellate the brain into
three-dimensional puzzle pieces
which we call regions of interest these
regions of
interest allow you to do very
interesting morphometry studies where
you measure
the volume the surface area the fractal
dimension the curvature the shape index
a whole bunch of morphometry measures on
each of these
original locations and these
morphometry measures are the key to
establishing homologies
between individuals because two brains
can never be made perfectly homologous
voxel by voxel is what i mean however
when you
when you personally the brains you can
various morphometry measures that you
can derive from this
can be made into homo into data
computable objects
and that's where the action comes up at
the far right
that tells you now that you have this
information you can find out
who are the populations that are more
predisposed for this condition
who are the populations that tend to
live longer have
have better quality of life and so forth
and obviously these decisions are going
to feed you back into collecting new
data
and so the process the cyclical process
of big data to
action continues now
i am fairly sure that most of you are
firm delivered so i don't have to spend
a whole lot of time here
but it is important to understand that
um
the notion of data sharing is critical
if we are going to be
making sustained advances forward one of
the element that i just want to mention
is the kreider's law
and the kreider's law dictates that the
volume of data increases exponentially
which can be compared to the moore's law
which gives you
an exponential increase in the compute
power the really interesting
uh phenomenon here is that the kreider's
law
out performs the moore's law in other
words
the rate at which we collect data
outpaces the way the rate at which our
computational power increases
so we have to be very very sensitive of
you know hoarding data because we're
holding up the data its value decreases
exponentially as well
so there's a lot of intricate notions so
most of us are firm supporters of
findable accessible interoperable
reusable
and recyclable data sets
as you can imagine over the past decade
uh actually two decades
a huge cloud ecosystem has emerged
that has you know back-end database
constructs workflow mechanisms
analytical platforms big data to
knowledge
uh interfaces and so forth so
uh there's a lot that's done and there
is a lot more that are done
every day to add to these cloud services
but they're important
for the scientific discovery uh
professor van horn and myself and
have built over the past uh again over a
decade now
an environment that we call the pipeline
graphical workflow environment
that allows you to do large-scale
computing on massive amounts of
heterogeneous data
data that had these seven
characteristics that i outlined
early on right when you have to have
some of us sometimes our data has to go
literally through
hundreds of steps imagine having to do
this
one step at a time uh for one
case or one subject individually it's
practically impossible for thousands of
of patients with uh with with variety of
uh kind of information for each patient
so we build a pipeline graphical
workflow environment that allows us to
automate this notion of
designing a graphical protocol
in a canvas where each module is an
executable
or a group of executable modules and it
gets
fed various data sets and it outputs
various data sets that are fed
downstream to the next module
so it's a very powerful mechanism that
we've developed
now in terms of uh to in terms of open
science
you know sharing data is insufficient
you know open access publications
many of us are huge supporters i just
want to remind you you know
recently uh gregory perlman proved a
ponca race conjecture in about 15 years
ago by publishing two
open access papers on archive you know
the guy sits in his office publishes two
papers publishes
uh proves a result that's a hundred
years old in the standing
hundreds and thousands of people have
died very sad for not being able to
prove it
and now it's it's fully documented into
open access papers
please do consider the notion of open
access publications are great
consider also things like blogs the
mathematics community has proven
a whole bunch of theorems by literally
starting a blog on a topic
when people chime in from different
perspectives all of a sudden
approve emerges incredible feats now
there is also cloud services
many of these are not open but the
cranium
pipeline grid server that we have is
available at usc
uh there is also software hubs for
sharing data
you can look at some of ours there is
also
learning modules look at the dspa the
data science and predictive analytics
we have six to seven million users
downloading some of these books
that we've built for our based
predictive analytics
and then licensing when it comes to
licensing ultimately
in our in our group in the soccer
resource we use cc by
permissive licenses for content and then
and then um uh uh you know
uh uh lesser gnu license
for the software code so these are all
parts of the notion of an open science
now there are some cons with open
science right i mean i've heard people
being concerned of somebody scooping
them or getting something published
before they
can you know there is also the notion of
predatory science
journals you know but these are these
are small troubles that most of the time
are easy to
uh to resolve you know um
but there are significant pros okay and
one of the most significant pros to open
science
is that the return on investment is
substantially
and rapidly increase when we share
information knowledge data protocols and
techniques
so expeditious discovery um
you know long-term sustainability of a
project i mean everybody knows you know
students leave postdocs graduate
you know people move on in their careers
you know
the the notion of opening uh something
to the community allows
collective um uh support
for long-term sustainability of
obviously not every project but the
projects that are worth
supporting and the last point i want to
make here is that especially with data
sets
holding data and doing clandestine
science
is obfuscated science it rapidly
decreases the value of any of these
and here is just one uh pseudo example
that i'm showing you
if you stop uh you know the value of
your data exponentially increases as you
keep collecting it the moment you stop
collecting it
its value begins to diminish
the more you hoard it the less valuable
it is
now this slide simply uh points out uh
for for the cases of neuroimaging and
genomics
this very interesting paradigm that
they're both increasing exponentially
but the amount of volume that we're
collecting
increases much faster than our
computational power
to manage it now let me tell you about
the first thing that we have developed
uh people say you know people have been
hiding for
uh quite frankly decades now behind uh
irb regulations uh ferpa
hippo regulations and so forth this is
not a barrier anymore
there are at least three different
strategies that allow you to
manipulate your data to make it
non-human one is called
epsilon differential privacy one is
called fully homomorphic encryption
we have developed a third level of
strategy called statistical obfuscation
via data shifting so this is we have a
pattern to this we have publications
you don't have to use our technique the
important is that
uh and it's actually available on github
as you can see
we have a mechanism to allow
a full spectrum of sharing of data where
for one of the levels of this ada
parameter which which is actually a
composite parameter of a whole bunch of
other
moving parts or variables or control
parameters
so we we synthesize these into a single
parameter that says if
eta is zero you release the data on the
clear
that's one of the extreme and as ada
increases all the way up to one
at the level of one you don't release
human subject data
what you release is synthetic simulated
data from the model joint distribution
so i hope everybody can can see here
that
if you have a data set that's you know
very powerful that people might be able
outside of your
immediate collaborator group or outside
of your skill set might be able to do
something interesting with it
with the data center you can
statistically perfectly obfuscate it
to the point where you release simulated
version of it
which is going to have a little bit of a
compromised energy or information
content but nonetheless
it's going to be a representative sample
from the same
space from the same state space
that the actual data is collected from
except it's not human
because it's synthesized there is zero
reasons not to share it
so if anybody tells you that there is a
reason why they cannot share the data
they're not telling you the truth a
little bit about the data shifter here
uh that i want to mention let's look at
this little animation you have two users
jan and joe from different institutions
they don't know about each other
but they know of a health system that
has some data that they want to try
their techniques on
so they fire up a request to the health
system and say hey do you guys have
subjects that fit that profile we're
looking for a cohort
that query is being translated into sql
structure query language or no sql query
the institution looks locally it
identifies the cases
it sends them to the data sifting
process by controlling this level
how comfortable am i sharing any data
with jane and joe
if jane and joe are vulcanized
uh unknown subjects we're gonna go all
the way up to one we don't trust them at
all we're going to pipe the data through
this
iterative statistical application
process in which
you know data is being manipulated
in a very clever way multiple times
with the goal being two points first of
all
preserve at every step of this iterative
process
preserve the distribution of the joint
features
and the second goal is generate the
complete data set
complete computable usable
object that can be sent to the user jane
and joe
they can go ahead and do their magic you
know
develop a graphical workflow environment
pipe the data through it generate some
results
and then hopefully they're good citizens
and they go back to the health system
and say hey this is what we found
uh are you willing to dial down a little
bit the obfuscation
to send us a little bit more signal to
send us data with a little bit more
information
with higher utility and as these
partnerships form
you can all imagine that it's going to
be better for all human experiences and
certainly for
managing human health now somebody's
going to ask well how do you know that
this thing works
and what is the effect of that
manipulation
this magic that you're doing on the data
well
in this graph here i'm just showing you
on the horizontal axis we have
data released on the clear no no
manipulation
small level of obfuscation in the middle
we have
a moderate level of obfuscation large
level obfuscation
at the extreme you synthetically sample
from the data
now on the vertical axis you have an
estimate of
what proportion of the features are
being altered
for every case and as you can imagine
most of the data with higher obfuscation
most of the data elements are going to
be twisted they're going to be
manipulated
in a very clever way and you can see the
different colors simply represents
binary features
categorical features continuous features
in the second level of validation that
we've done we've looked at
you know how do various i mean this
obfuscation process changing my
inference yeah that's the biggest
question that anybody wants to know
after the question of is my data
secure when i appreciate it so
the second question about are you
preserving the utility of the
information his answer by looking at
how does again on the horizontal axis
level of obfuscation from no
to high extreme obfuscation how is he
changing
the level of the true positives in this
logistic model
that we've used here uh in in this case
and as you can see
you know the true positives are going to
decrease in other words we're going to
be committing a lot more
false positive errors as you can see up
here on the right plot as well
the the false inference is going to be
increasing with the level of obfuscation
and this is to be expected right but
nonetheless you still can make
some inference and the most extreme uh
synthetic data generation mode of the
whole system
and just to give you uh one last example
here in this data shifter algorithm
we have looked at a large database
called a byte database
which stands for autism brain imaging
data exchange
and just to give you an idea of what
does this data shift in a different
levels of statistical application do we
pulled out the random subject the 22nd
abide pediatric case from the database
originally this was an autistic kid a
male
of age 31 and the acquisition plane
it's referring to the structural mri
data was a certain type
um and um we can see that we have
different
measures of cortical thickness curvature
and
gaussian feature and so forth and as we
as we increase
each row represents a different level of
increasing the manipulation of the data
you see at the extreme case at the
bottom
this individual from a patient became a
control
the age was changed even the acquisition
plane was changed
so somebody's going to say this is
insane how is this making sense
well this is precisely what's intended
to do
on an individual case by case
the data sifter manipulates the data to
the point where it's
unrecognizable but nobody wants to use
the data shifter to do
precision individualized medicine you
want to use the data sifter to do
cohort based or population-wide studies
and that's where the power of this
approach comes
because i'm not interested in any one of
the subjects
i'm interested in the joint information
that they
carry collectively and that information
is being protected not perfectly
preserved
but protected as you dial up
the level of your statistical
obfuscation
okay let me now show you one case one
different case for for a normal cohort
population
so this is the uh united kingdom biobank
data
uh you know they need to be commended in
the uk you know they did this right they
started
close to 10 years ago they decided look
we have so much
talent in this country and we have so
much data
except that our stem investigators don't
have access to
clinical data what are we going to do
about it said and they said
you know well in fact uk is a small
nation whatever 80 million people
maybe 60 i don't know the exact number
but what about
what about globalizing and letting all
the 8 billion people out there
help us extract remember in my
synthetic workflow go from the raw data
to information
to knowledge and to action so they saw
the light
over a decade ago and they decided we're
going to do this so
millions of people have committed to
contribute to this data set
now obviously there is proper
regulations people sign data use
agreements
irb approvals you know this is done in
the right way
we are part of a team that has an
agreement to use the uk biobank data
here's the reference
anybody's public data set you can apply
you can get this data
now in our case we looked at
a half a million patients and we
extracted all the patients that had
imaging data and about
4 000 clinical features about these
individuals
now the imaging data included t1
weighted fmri and so forth and it also
had genetic data
so what we're going to be doing now here
is imagine 4 000 features
the imaging data it's a mass you know
and even if you have only about 10 000
individuals that have all of these data
the problem is complex for multiple
reasons
here is one reason if you guys remember
again in the very beginning when i
outlined the seventh dimension of big
data
i said the last but not least important
characteristic
was that it's never complete now here
are the most frequently observed
remember there is 4 000 clinical
features
i'm just plotting the
most frequently observed for these 10
000
individuals uh features and there is
the features that have at least 30
percent of the cases a measurement for
that feature
so you see there is precisely 1475 of
these
features out of 4 000 where at least 30
observed everything else is very very
sparsely observed
okay and on the vertical i'm showing you
out of the 10 000
how many individuals actually have these
features so you look at this pattern
the point i'm trying to get across is
that the missingness is
not at random and because missingness is
not at random this presents a huge
problem when it comes to doing
imputation statistical inference
even machine learning and model model
free inference
so what we've done for this you know
capitalizing on what i mentioned earlier
cloud services the pipeline graphical
workflow environment
we build a workflow that has about 98
different steps that all the data needs
to go through
all the way up from the volumetric
pre-processing the partialization that i
show you
the extraction of the morphometry
features because we are trying to
establish homologies between
the brains of all these individuals
because we already have the homologies
between the clinical features right the
clinical features there are precise
columns in our data we don't have
chromologies between the brains
we establish the homologies between the
brain using this pipeline workflow
and as you can imagine on this massive
scale hundreds of processing steps
uh you know thousands of individuals
everything is not going to be perfect
so in this specific case i have 97
completion rate
sometimes i have 99 completion rate some
modules are canceled
most are successful but i can drill down
and find out
why and how any of these modules
failed and if so what was the cause of
failure
so we built this protocol right we start
off with these half a million
observations
4 300 features then we have 10 000 of
these individuals
for which we extracted 3 200 derived
neuroimaging biomarkers
just like i told you right we personally
the brain for every region we have
volume surface area for active dimension
a whole bunch of morphometry measures so
we compile here is my computable data
object
computable data object thousand
individuals
7 500 features and then we do
uh both model based and model free
inference in the model free inference
we are interested in well you know
pretend we don't know anything about
these patients because we don't it's a
census the uk biobank is essentially a
population census
so we said okay we don't know anything
about these individuals go ahead and do
a kind of clustering you know complete
clustering of the data
turns out we use hierarchical in this
case two clusters emerge
over and over again no matter how we
start
with data you know um cluster one
and cluster two right um and as you can
see between the
k-means clustering and the hierarchical
there was a fair amount of agreement
right whoever is in cluster one on one
clustering was in the same cluster
according to the separate and
independent clustering and then we did
this repeatedly with different
initial conditions multiple times and we
observed the consistency of
getting individuals to forward in the
same
group is very very high in other words
if you and i are in the same group at
one clustering we are extremely
likely to be in the same group using a
different type of clustering
the variance was very very small the
cluster sizes mysteriously were
it was pretty balanced you know about
half and half
and there is a silhouette measure of how
good the clustering is
and then we actually wanted to answer
the following question now the
clinician is going to always ask you a
question fine you got two groups
but what does it mean you know what are
these two groups
can you explicate these groups in
something that i
understand in terms of the clinical
phenotype of these individuals
that's the question that every clinician
wants to know and every research
scientist wants to know
so remember thousands of different
features
for the two clusters so what we do here
is we actually look at each of these
measures and try to find out which of
these measures
contributes significantly to separating
these clusters right to segregating
these clusters
and that gives us an explication of
which variables are important
to separate if you want a more explicit
uh example here is one where we looked
at
trying to explicate depression feelings
one of the four thousand and three
hundred clinical measures
was a measure called depression feelings
we tried to predict here you using a
decision tree method to predict decision
tree
and then here is the decision tree right
you start off you you ask
about some of the psychological state of
the individual their gender and so forth
and then this decision tree separates
them into groups and it reports the
probability that
if you fall within this group you're 56
likely to be part of one depression
feeling cluster versus
the other one right some groups are
better separated like this group for
example is perfectly separated
they're almost exclusively of the second
type
right this group here is predominantly
the first type and so is this one right
so in this decision tree we can actually
find out or explicate
uh some of the clinically relevant
information
uh we also looked at not only uh
depression we looked at sensitivity
uh warrior uh types miserableness that
people have reported
and then we report the accuracy of
various methods
uh this is of course using random forest
classification and this is cross
validation tenfold cross validation
so in the final part um and i know
probably people would have questions i i
i think we're going to have a chance in
about 10 15 minutes to ask the questions
at the end
but i'm going to now transition to a new
method that we're developing which is
very very interesting
it essentially answers the following
question
why are we doing repeated
multiple sampling when we want to do an
inference on a data set
and the argument is that the reason why
we're making repeated samples think
about
fmri most of us know functional magnetic
resonance images
the subject stands sits in the scanner
and is repeatedly undergoing the same
conditioning the same uh stimulus the
same
state and we measure um the
the corresponding bold signal repeatedly
and the reason for this is that the
signal to noise ratio is so small about
four percent
that and the noise level is so high that
if you just look at an
instance at a one observation you're
never going to be able to find
any effect of the external stimulus
on the brain activation network or the
brain activation regions
there is no way to do it so what do you
do well we use
the tried and tested method for a
thousand years that's what cavendish did
200 years ago
to establish the mean dynasty of the
earth what did you do he required 23
observations and he
averaged them once he averaged them a
statistician told him that he needs to
compute also the variability
no problem that's how we estimate the
confidence interval that's exactly what
happens with the fmri
why averaging though and i'm sure
everybody has asked this question why
average
because averaging acts as a denoising
and once you denoise
the signal-to-noise ratio increases
now in the framework that we're
proposing
is we're generalizing the notion of
event
longitudinal order something that we
refer as time
we are generalizing this notion as a
two-dimensional
complex time something that we call time
and it's got this mathematical
representation over here
so in other words to compress
the three-dimensional space universe
okay of up down left and right the
the three-dimensional spaces here in
this diagram compressed
into a single dimensional line
and orthogonal to it we actually have
the two-dimensional
complex time the radius the radial
direction of how far
are you gives you the time displacement
or the
longitudinal event order but then there
is a second variable it's not just
how far away it's what phase
direction you're into and this
is the important thing so if you
understand this notion of complexifying
the notion of time and this kind of
diagram
kind of tells you so this event right up
here x
x and y are two different spatial
locations just like my two hands
but two points on the red circle on the
left on the red circle
there are two events that happen at the
x
spatial location whereas the points over
here on the blue circle
they happen at the separate y location
so these events here
these events kappa 1 and kappa 4
occur at exactly the same longitudinal
instance
at the exactly the same time but there
are multiple instantiations
so in fmri lingo this is
fmri repeat 1 repeat 2 under the same
states now kappa 2 is different from
kappa 1
because kappa 2 and capital 2 have
different radii
in other words there they appear at the
same location x
okay but they are taken at two different
longitudinal
space longitudinal space times
as you can imagine there is different
mathematical representations we can
represent that complex plane in multiple
coordinates
now let me give you one important thing
of why is it
necessary to model this notion of the
phase of time
and i understand this is a little bit of
a heuristic example
it only it's a cartoon if you wish but
it represents the importance of
capturing the right
phases of the time observations
so we're going to start with two images
one is a square on the left and right
here in the middle i have a disk
each of these two images we are going to
pipe through the fourier transform
and get the fourier m the real part of
the fourier transform
the magnitude of the fourier transform
of the square and the phase
of the fourier transform of the square
here on the right hand side i have
exactly the same three features
a plot of the real image of the fourier
transform which by the way is a complex
number that's why we're
taking only the real part of it the
magnitude is the square of the real part
plus the square of the imaginary part
square root of and then the phase
is the actual arc tangent of the x over
y
now if you abandon the phases if you
for a second ignore the phases and try
to
invert uh the fourier transform by using
the magnitudes and the phases you're
going to get a perfect square right if
you use the right magnitude and the
phase of the square you get the square
but if you use the um square magnitude
if you use this magnitude but new but
the
the the phase of the disk so in other
words you take this
with that instead of this with that to
recover the disk the the square
you get something that looks like a b
square it's a disc square it's a blend
and it's got certain as you can see
aliasing effects here
so the phase information is critical
to do the inference if you completely
abandon the face if you say i don't know
the face
i'm gonna set this whole thing to be
zero flat image
and i'm gonna take these two with the
flat face invert the fourier transform
i get something that yeah topologically
it's a square all right
but as an imaging it's a star-shaped
object
okay that has a negative curvature for
that matter right
so if you do exactly the same thing
starting with the magnitude of the disc
and use the square phases instead you
get something that
kind of looks like a the square circle
here but it's a
circle square here right a little bit of
a different ringing effect
but look what happens over here if you
negate the phases
the magnitude of the of the disk are
pretty much sufficient because
look this and this image i am
comfortable doing
inference on this instead of on that so
in other words the phase
for the circle did not make a whole
bunch of difference
the phase of the of the square made a
much more significant difference
so ignoring the kind phases corresponds
to essentially doing what we've been
doing for a while
space time standard classical analytics
in the extension space in this higher
dimensional
manifold that we call space time uh
things are a little bit different
and here is a schematic for instance of
what happens to a real fmri data
okay here here is a a two-dimensional uh
fmri data
that we're gonna look across time and we
are
only going to be plotting an iso surface
not
because you know if you plug the whole
fmri solid volume over time
you're not going to be able to peer
through it right so we're just plotting
the iso surfaces you see you see how
different the iso surfaces are if you
ignore
the phases and how much more detail in
the iso surfaces is available
if you account for the corresponding
phases
so it is important by making the
argument to
understand the kind phases
now uh one can ask well what's the
rationale for doing this
well the rationale is threefold first of
all
in a mathematical sense minkowski
four-dimensional space time that we are
all very accustomed to using
is an unsettling beast right because
time
is only positive real it doesn't even
form
it forms algebraically a multiplicative
group all right
but um uh because it allows
multiplicative inversion
but it but is not a complete algebraic
field right because simply the additive
the additive unity zero does not allow
you to invert additive you can't it can
go to a time minus five
so you can do really nice things that we
are accustomed to
so it's not a field second of all
equations of this type have no solutions
in time
okay whereas in time a polynomial of
order n has precisely and uh
and solutions so this notion from a
mathematical sense
it's much more settling to have space
time
represent a field as opposed to a
partial
uh uh you know multiplicative algebraic
group
the second important characteristics is
in physics space kind formulation
allows us to solve some of the problems
of time and here's a reference i'm not
going to dwell too much into this
but the third one is where most of you
are going to be interested in
for artificial intelligence and data
science
space kind representations allow us to
transform random iid sampling
into a different strategy for acquiring
and interpreting
repeated experimental conditions
second of all it allows a bayesian
representation of that inference
it allows tensor based modeling on what
you're going to see in a second are
called
chyme surfaces and it allows the
development of really really
innovative ai and machine learning
techniques
okay also i need to let you know that
it's natural when you define a new space
right
can you do calculus in this space that's
that's the first question a
mathematician is going to ask you
right can you do differentiation and the
answer is yes you can do
vertinger type derivatives on these
on the kind variable which remember is a
two-dimensional uh
complex time representation and here are
the
the the time derivatives uh in cartesian
coordinates in polar coordinates
in uh conjugate pairs and so forth and
once you have integration
the opposite operation is called uh i'm
sorry once you have differentiation the
opposite operation is called
integration we can actually define the
path integral
and correspondingly the area integral
indefinite integral
uh laplacian operators as it stays here
in conjugate pairs terms
and so forth so now with all this
uh uh kind of
basic fundamental science what is truly
the relation
between artificial intelligence
quantum mechanics and data science
this is a very simple table that we drew
to show that
what we call in mathematical physics
particles these become objects in data
science what we call observables
become features states become datum
systems become problems and the most
important one
what physicists refer to as wave
functions
in data science and ai they become
inference functions
and that's where we are going to be
spending a whole lot of time here is
just one example
uh you know when you talk about the wave
function the wave function is a solution
to a certain equation it's got certain
behavior we can plot it we can
we can project you know uh
how it propagates in space time we can
do the dynamics of these elements and so
forth so a lot is known about wave
functions
well the same thing so here is one of
the two examples actually
of how we do these wave functions now
remember their inference functions in
our little space
the first example is just a standard
linear model based representation of a
solution so
right up here the inference function is
going to be a function of the
of of of all the data that includes both
predictors
and outcomes okay so this inference
function
is simply the one that's used when we do
the classical
um for instance or really squares
estimates right
you're given the x and y you manipulate
these things here is the inference
function
once i have the beta estimates i can say
well what's the likelihood that these
beta coefficients are not trivial
so this leads me to probability values
and from probability values to
likelihood and therefore i can do
predictions
in the non-parametric non-linear case
something very similar happens in
support vector machine classification
for example
we have a lifting function that
increases dimensionality of my data
in such a way that some of the nonlinear
borders in the lower dimensional space
can be inflated to become more of a
linear
borders or barriers between different
classes of functions
this can also be formulated as an
inference function in terms of the
observations as you can see
and and this kind of shows you the
parallel between the two types of
strategies here from quantum mechanics
to artificial intelligence
so how do we do this space-time
inference well we're going to do exactly
what
crystallographers have done for many
many decades at least
half a century they've basically looked
at
um uh the uh uh
projections the um projections of of
bombarding various crystals that they
generate with high energy particles
and they look at the diffraction
patterns that are on the back they can
estimate
the magnitudes of the diffractions but
not the phases
and they've invented strategies to
handle that that's precisely what we're
going to be doing
we're going to be using similar strategy
but in our case it's going to be a
transformation like the fourier
transform or the laplace transform
that's going to allow us to do this uh
to infer
the enigmatic phases and here is just
one example uh here is again the
astrosurface that i showed you
when you recover this thing using no
face or no information about the face
you you get the iso surface on the left
when you use the right faces
you get a little bit more topologically
correct ventricular
uh projection of of that time course of
just one two-dimensional
slice in the true three-dimensional case
imagine me picking just one voxel of the
fmri data at one specific location
and tracking it over time what i want to
do now is i want to
recut that time voxel as a kind surface
as a complex time surface where time
again represents the radial
direction on this surface and the face
uh
i'm sorry the and the face represents
the angular direction
of this of these uh of this menu so this
is an idealized
this is an idealized fmri series for
just
one voxel location
now if you want to know what happens for
for multiple representations
um because we're kind of running out of
time a little bit
i will skip over uh the bayesian
representation
and just show you perhaps yeah this one
example suppose i'm having
a finger tapping a finger tapping uh
experiment
here here is one example that that's
kind of illustrated here
i can reconstruct the on and off so
people are doing this
and then resting doing it again remember
to repeat it resting again
doing the finger tapping again and
resting so what we can do is we can
extract to go to a specific location
extract the data
and then ultimately reconstruct what we
call the uh
on off fmrim kind surface so this is the
entire fmri
looking as a surface because now this
surface has interesting
topology and interesting geometry it's
got curvature some areas are highly
curved
some areas are highly flat you know this
is information
that we can use then to actually
pinpoint that exactly the somatosensory
cortex
is where the statistical analysis
happened to be
for this highly uh sensitive data
so in the last few minutes before we
open up for questions i want to let you
know that again
our group at the statistics online
computational resource and the michigan
institute for data science
is firm supporters of data science we
are working on big data analytics
uh we are sharing all of our code many
services are available on the soccer
website github projects and apps are
available for you to
interact with and the secret sauce just
like for many other groups is
teamwork you know here is here's the
team that has produced all these and
many more resources
and here is our funding so with that
thank you very much and i'll be happy uh
professor van horn if there are any
questions to address them in the last
few minutes
thank you dr deanna thank you so much
for that
amazing talk that's a fantastic amount
of work thank you so much for sharing
that with us we have a
question from one of our viewers who has
two questions
um one is practically speaking who would
i need to include on my study team in
order to use the data sifter tool
um they felt that they might not be
quite uh a droid enough at using a
github or understanding how to navigate
it and who could they reach out to to
better understand that
there's a second question oh i'll ask
you you answer that one first i'll ask
the second question in a second
okay so the answer to the first question
is thank you for that question
uh it's a good question so the answer is
twofold first of all if you're doing
this for some kind of a monetary
incentive
you have to go through and get a license
for this product
okay so you have to go through the
university of michigan it's a patented
technology you get
you you get a license and use it if you
use it for research and education
then you go to the to the website
download the code and and obviously
as you can imagine highly complicated
software
are not very easy we're not we're not
you know
google we're not facebook you know we
don't have enough
to to make production quality code so
you will have to have
an id expert to help you deploy it
and run it on your system if that makes
sense
one follow-up question to that are there
any irb
concerns um that you've run into with
people using this i'm thinking of
you know data anonymization versus
obfuscation
do irbs have any problem with that yeah
so this is so remember the issue is that
the data governor whoever owns the data
they get to decide the level of
obfuscation
you still need an irb even if you go to
the highest
level for synthetically generating data
simply because
the irb needs to have a non-human
exemption for you if you're at an
academic institution i believe
at any other institution you still have
to go but but these these are
expeditious
now if you intend to share data that's
somewhere
in the in the middle level right
small moderate to large obfuscation
you have to go through the rigorous now
full-blown irb approval
where you have to actually do a case
study to find out how
identifiable because the risk will not
be zero
but look if you're looking for zero risk
uh you you you need to close shop and
and just do nothing
but fair enough but yeah fair enough uh
the second question was uh regarding the
missingness not at random
and uh whether or not um we were all
understanding correctly that for the uk
bio bank in particular the cancer case
studies that features with less than 70
completeness were thrown out um i missed
what to do about that
uh this particular asker is asking uh
what do you do about that
when you find that situation that is
that is an excellent question
and to be perfectly honest with you this
is the
art okay why is this the art
because there is no rule of thumb if
anybody told you that they have a recipe
don't trust them it's wrong uh but the
the
the basic strategy not a recipe but a
strategy
is what box and box a long time ago has
said
if you know something has an effect
model it
everything else you have to randomize
now what this means in that to answer
that specific question is that
you have to ask yourself is there a
rationale
for me to expect some of these cases to
be missing
and if the answer is yes then you have
to
put some kind of a correction factor on
this
value that you added you have to edit
you have to add an
uncertainty to that specific value if
you know what i mean
if you don't know uh then
to be perfectly strict about you know to
be orthodoxy
the statistician is going to say well
you know if the date is not missing at
random
i can't do anything for you simply
because either you
tell me what the missing pattern or or
or the missing effect is
or if you know it's not at random
we just can't do anything because we we
just don't know you're shooting in the
dark
so it is an art but speaking with an
expert
will help you figure out ways to
introduce
reasonable not perfect but reasonable
way of imputing your data sets
okay one other question i have uh
evo is that the kind uh
concept is fascinating and i'm get
you've looked at
you look like you're looking at time
series analytics using this
i was kind of curious if you've extended
this to network theoretical
examination where the networks are
working
on the time space instead of in say
standard time for example
yeah uh this is a great uh question jack
we haven't gotten to that point yet we
have not
yet worked at the networks but it is
certainly very very interesting a
question and it will be interesting to
see how the networks
reflect this notion of the of the kind
phase and kind magnitude so i don't have
an answer unfortunately for you yet
i just would be interested to hear about
that when you get around to it
um because of course that phase
differential between different locations
in that space is going to be reflective
of any sort of
time lag that might be between them um
and that could carry some useful
information
um you know about rates of information
flow and
you know you could extend that to
information theoretical frameworks as
well
obviously a natural extension of some of
the work in the bayesian space that
you've been working in
absolutely yeah fantastic well
i think we've kind of reached the end of
our hour and
i really want to thank uh uh my
colleague and friend uh evo diana for
sharing
some of his amazing work with us uh this
has really been helpful to
one contextualize what we think of with
big
data analytics uh in the brain space and
some strategies to kind of address it
uh to uh examine it and then to
conceptualize it
i really appreciate you taking the time
today dr tino so thank you
and thank you to everyone for joining us
and uh everyone we will see you next
week in the meantime have a great
weekend
thanks very much